WITH RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY AND- WELCOME TO. THE
REV AND TAX COMMITTEE HEARING OF
MR FONG LUCKILY YOU ARE THE ONLY
PERSON HERE SO- WE ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND- DO ARE YOUR
WITNESSES HERE. HOW OKAY WELL
THEN YOU ARE NOT QUITE AS LUCKY
AS- I THOUGHT YOU WERE. SORRY
WELL THE- LOS.
ALL RIGHTS- I WILL GO AHEAD
WE'LL WAIT FOR WE'RE GONNA SEE
WHO COMES IN FIRST MY WITNESS
ARE YOUR WITNESS. THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TODAY'S. TO TODAY'S
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ROBIN TAX I WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT FOR THIS AND
FUTURE HEARINGS- TESTIMONIES
MUST BE IN PERSON AS WE ARE NO
LONGER USING MODERATED A
TELEPHONE SERVICE WE ARE HOWVER
ACCEPTING. A WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE FOR THE BILLS BEING
TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL TAKE NO
MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WITH CONCERNS THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TO- MINUTES
EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION THEIR POSITION ON
THEIR BILL ONLY ON THE BILL
ONLY. FINALLY I WISH TO ANNOUNCE
THAT FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. YOU ALREADY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. WE HAVE PRESENT
PRESENTING- TWENTY EIGHT TO
THIRTY FIVE AB. ATTESTING TO ALL
RIGHT. HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE NO
ONE WITH SUPER GLUE THIS TIME
AROUND- SINCE LAST TIME I SAID
THIS YEAR- I THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS. A BLOOD DONATION SAVED
COUNTLESS LIVES ACROSS THE STATE
AND NATION ACCORDING TO THE
BLOOD CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA
SOMEONE NEEDS A BLOOD
TRANSFUSION EVERY THREE SECONDS
AND BLOOD BANKS ARE RUNNING
DANGEROUSLY LOW ON SUPPLIES.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE WOULD EXEMPT BLOOD BANKS
FROM SALES AND USE TAXES TO HELP
THEM RAMP UP COLLECTION TO MEET
THE INCREASED DEMAND FOR BLOOD
PRODUCTS AND MISS A NATIONAL
BLOOD SHORTAGE DONATED BLOOD
PRODUCTS ARE USED TO TREAT
INJURIES AND DISEASES RANGING
FROM CANCER HEART DISEASE ORGAN
TRANSPLANTS TO SEVERE TRAUMATIC
INJURIES. IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT WE RELY ON THE KINDNESS AND
GENEROSITY OF BLOOD DONORS TO
HELP SAVE SECOND GLOBAL
CALIFORNIANS EVERY DAY BUT THE
PANDEMIC HAS TRIPLED OUR BLOOD
SUPPLY AND HOSPITALS ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF WHOLE BLOOD
AND BLOOD COMPONENTS. EARLIER
THIS YEAR A TRAUMA CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES HAD TO TEMPORARILY CLOSE
BECAUSE OF INADEQUATE BLOOD
SUPPLY. CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
FEW STATES. THAT REQUIRE THEIR
NONPROFIT BLOOD CENTERS TO PAY
SALES AND USE TAXES. IN LIGHT OF
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
THE STALL OF ELECTIVE SURGERIES
DEMAND FOR THAT PRODUCT TO
INCREASE AND NONPROFIT BLOOD
CENTERS CAN RISE TO MEET THAT
DEMAND. BY PROVIDING TAX RELIEF
TO BLOOD DONATION CENTERS
FINANCIAL RESOURCES CAN BE FREED
UP. FOR THEM TO BE FLEXIBLE
SOLICIT DONORS AND RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE SHORT ASIAN AND
HAVE UPCOMING BUT- LET'S DRIVES.
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE. HAS
GRANTED SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTIONS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE PAST.
WITHOUT PROVIDING REIMBURSEMENT
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I AM
SENSITIVE TO THE POSITION OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES SO I
PREPARED AMENDMENTS TO REIMBURSE
THEM. FOR THE LOCAL PIECE OF
SALES AND USE TAXES. AS A NODE
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I'M ALSO OPEN TO
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
TO REDUCE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THE STATE. I'M JOINED BY LYDIA
BORN ON BEHALF OF THE BLOOD
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE ONE
REPRESENTING THE BLOOD CENTERS
OF CALIFORNIA WITH SUPPORT FROM
THE NINE. OKAY NOT A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED BLOOD CENTER
COALITION MEMBERS. BCC MEMBERS
PROVIDE OVER 90% OF THE BLOOD
AND BLOOD PRODUCTS. REQUIRED IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE HIGHLY
REGULATED INDUSTRY. THE F. D. A.
N. A. A. B. B. WHICH IS TO.
SHORTED FOR THE ASSOCIATION FOR
ADVANCEMENT OF BLOOD IN BIO
THERAPIES GOVERN OUR OPERATIONS
AND ANY STANDARDS GENERATED BY
THE A. A. B. B. BECOME LAW IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER A NINETY DAY
WAITING PERIOD- WE ASSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE BLOOD SUPPLY BY
COLLECTING FROM AN ALL
VOLUNTEER. DONOR BASE THE BLOOD
SUPPLY IS THE SAFEST THERE'S
EVER BEEN. BASED ON THE SALES
AND USE TAX EXEMPTIONS ALLOWED
FOR NON PROFITS INCLUDING ONE OF
OUR LARGEST BLOOD CENTERS
AMERICAN RED CROSS WE ARE
SEEKING PARITY. WE DO HAVE A
LIMITED EXEMPTION FROM SALES AND
USE TAX ON CONTAINERS OF BLOOD
PLASMA AND BLOOD DERIVATIVES
INCLUDING THE TUBING FILTERS AND
NEEDLES HOWEVER. THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPLIES THAT INCREASE COSTS
SUCH AS BLOOD SCREENING TESTS AS
WELL AS THE REAGENTS EQUIPMENT
AND OTHER SUPPLIES THESE COST
INCREASE OUR DELIVERY OF THIS
VALUABLE COMMUNITY SERVICE.
MULTIPLE OTHER STATES TOTAL
EXEMPT THEIR BLOOD CENTERS FROM
SALES TAXES WHEN PURCHASING SUCH
SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT. THE TAX
EXEMPTION WE REQUEST WILL FREE
UP DOLLARS THAT COULD BETTER BE
SPENT ON EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
ABOUT BLOOD ISSUES RECRUITING
AND RETAINING DONORS. INCREASING
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
AND CONTINUING TO ASSURE THE
SAFETY AND EFFICACY OF THE BLOOD
SUPPLY FOR THESE ABOVE RISK
REASONS WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN THIS
ISSUE. IS CONSIDERED FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. ANY
OTHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. ALL RIGHT- DO WE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND I JUST HAVE OF
ONE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG- WITH THIS ALLOW BLOOD
BANKS TO PURCHASE ANY SORT OF
EQUIPMENT PROPERTY TAX FREE.
WELL I WOULD DOUBLE TO FERTILITY
BUT WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE-
ENVISIONED IT TO BE- FOR
SPECIFIC- QUITMAN BUT- AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON IF IT THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
WHY TO SPECIFY IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING. SPECIFIC EQUIPMENT TO
GET IT BUT- YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT THE
FACT THAT FOR EVERY HUNDRED
DOLLARS SPENT BY SOME BLOOD
CENTERS TO SEVEN TO TEN DOLLARS
WOULD BE SAVED IF THEY COULD GET
A SALES TAX USE EXEMPTION OF.
RIGHT ACTION AND TO- JUST TO ADD
A LITTLE OUT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE US ONLY MEANT TO KIND OF
COME UP WITH A LIST TO TRY TO
NARROW IT DOWN SOMEWHAT BUT
PRIMARILY MOST OF IT'LL BE
RELATED TO THE- EVALUATION OF
THE BLOOD THAT COMES IN I THINK
YOU WILL AS I STATED- WITH THE
BLOOD SUPPLY IS THE SAFEST IT'S
EVER BEEN. ARE THERE ARE ELEVEN
TESTS THAT WE HAVE TO.
ADMINISTER TO ANY BLOOD THAT
COMES IN AND WHILE IT'S- IT'S
NOT REALLY MANDATE IT BUT THE
FDA. SAYS THAT WE SHOULD DO THIS
AND CLEARLY IT MAKES SENSE IN
TERMS OF THE BLOOD SUPPLY BEING
SAFE BUT THAT'S WHAT COST US IS
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS ADD TO
THE COST OF PROVIDING BLOOD AND
BLOOD PRODUCTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT YEAH THANK
YOU ARE THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- I. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
. BOTH YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU AND- I AM GOING TO.
PASS THE GAVEL OVER TO OF. MY
VICE CHAIR AND- WILL MEET. OUR
TREASURE. WE WILL. RIGHT AND- WE
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBERONE
AB TWO TWO ONE SIX TEEN. WELL AB
TWO TO SIXTEEN AT ONE SIXTEEN.
RIGHT. MADAM CHAIR PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
ALL RIGHT NOT A VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED AB FOUR FOUR
NINE ESTABLISHING THE CAL ABLE
ACT WHICH ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES TO SAVE
MONEY WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR NEEDED PUBLIC BENEFITS. AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN WILL PROVIDE
STATU TORY UPDATES THE CALABAR
TO BETTER ALIGN WITH THE FEDERAL
ABLE ACT AND THE IRS REGULATIONS
FOR ABLE ACCOUNTS WITH THESE
CHANGES THE STATE WILL ENSURE
THAT THE CONTINUED SUCCESS OF
THE CALLEVA PROGRAM FURTHER
SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS WITH A
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES I THINK
THIS IS PROBABLY MY FIFTH OR SO-
CAL ABLE BILL AND SO ALWAYS
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH YOU- I'D
LIKE TO- OF- R. AS STATE
TREASURER. FIONA MA AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE KELLY
WILL PROGRAM DANTE ALAN. GIVE US
SOME SPEAKING POINTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS- GREAT TO SEE
EVERYONE HERE TODAY AND I WANT
TO THANK- SALUTE NUMBER IRWIN
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN A STAB
WISHING THIS VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM- I JUST GOT
ELECTED THREE AND A HALF YEARS
AGO AND SO THIS STARTED UNDER MY
PREDECESSOR JOHN CHUNG. AND IT'S
GREAT TO SEE NOW TODAY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FOURTH
LARGEST ABLE PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY SO THIS PROGRAM IS
ENABLING MORE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DIAGNOSED BEFORE
THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX TO OPEN UP
ACCOUNTS AND SAVE UP TO SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN THEIR OWN
NAME OUT WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
ANY OF THE OTHER SAFETY NET
BENEFITS THAT THEY DEPEND ON.
THIS BILL IS REALLY KIND OF A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL- FOR TWO
THINGS IN PARTICULAR NUMBER ONE
IT INCLUDES LANGUAGE TO
GRANDFATHER IN THOSE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WHO OPENED ABLE
ACCOUNTS AND OTHER STATES. IN
GOOD FAITH TO AVOID UNINTENDED
ADVERSE AFFECTS YOU ANY CURRENT
HOLDERS SINCE PEOPLE DO MOVE
FROM STATE TO STATE- IF THEY
COME TO CALIFORNIA THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO. MOVE THEIR MONEY INTO
CAL CALIFORNIA'S CAL ABLE
ACCOUNT WITHOUT- JEOPARDIZING
THEIR ACCOUNT AND THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
AND THE SECOND IS TO CONFORM
WITH THE FEDERAL IRS TAX
REGULATIONS- WHICH ENABLE
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE WORKING AND
NOT ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING IN AN
EMPLOYER SPONSORED RETIREMENT
PROGRAM TO CONTRIBUTE ABOVE THE
ANNUAL IRS GIFT TAX EXEMPTION
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT OF THE ABLE
PROGRAM- SO AGAIN THIS PROGRAM
IS WORKING WE ARE WORKING. UP IN
CONGRESS TO EXPAND THE AGE OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR DISABILITY TO
FORTY SIX YEARS OLD BECAUSE WE
KNOW PEOPLE- HAVE UNEXPECTED
ILLNESSES AND ACCIDENTS AFTER
THEIR TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD THIS
WOULD ENABLE SEVEN MILLION MORE.
AMERICANS TO PARTICIPATE.
INCLUDING ONE MILLION VETERANS
ARE SO WE REALLY AS IT IS MOVING
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER THROUGH
CONGRESS AS WE SPEAK. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF DANTE
ALLEN ARE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WHO'S BEEN HERE SINCE DAY ONE.
OF FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. AND BEING
REALLY THE EXPERT ONE OF THE
EXPERTS IN THE COUNTRY- ARE ABLE
PROGRAM SO THANK YOU DANTE THANK
YOU TREASURE MA. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN THE ONLY
THING THAT I WOULD ADD TO THAT
IS ONE OF THE- CONFUSING
CONFUSING MEASURES OF. THE
FEDERAL ABLE ACT WAS THIS IDEA
OF MEDICAID RECOVERY. IT ALLOWS
MEDICAID TO REIMBURSE ITSELF
USING MONEY FROM INDIVIDUALS
ABLE ACCOUNTWHEN THEY PASSED
AWAY. CALIFORNIA WE HAD THE
FORESIGHT EVEN BOAST FOR CALAIS
BOTH- WAS FULLY UP AND RUNNING.
TO PASS A LAW THAT SAID THAT-
MEDIC COW WILL NOT DO THAT FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- THERE WAS
A- A NEW ONCE IN THE LAW THAT
THAT IT SAID FOR ABLE ACCOUNT
HOLDERS. AND WE SEE THAT THE
MOST APPROPRIATE USE FOR THAT
WOULD BE TO PROMOTE OUR STATE
PROGRAM THE CALIBER PROGRAM
RATHER THAN ABLE PROGRAMS FROM
ALL OVER THE NATION. AND
PARTICIPATING IN OUR PROGRAM AND
RECEIVING THAT PROTECTION- THAT
LIMITS MEDICARE'S ABILITY TO
RECOVER. THANK YOUARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN THAT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS
ARE COMING FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THERE'S OF A SEVEN
MEMBER MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WELL WHEN WE HAVE-
ACTUALLY EVERYBODY HERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK OVER THE YEARS
ON THIS ISSUE IT IS IT IS REALLY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I HEAR
ABOUT MOST WHEN I TALK TO
PARENTS- THAT HAVE- DISABLED
CHILDREN IN MY COMMUNITY IT IT
IT HAS MADE A HUGE IMPACT. RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
RIGHT SO OUR NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. AND HOPEFULLY
WE WILL SOON GET TO OUR FULL
ATTENDANCE BUT RIGHT NOW YOU ARE
OBVIOUSLY- PRESENTING TO
SUBCOMMITTEE SO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINE SEVEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND DEATH GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I AM HERE. TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH ITS CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS BY
INCENTIVIZING INCREASED
PRODUCTION AND USE OF VERY LOW
TO CARBON NEUTRAL TRANSPORTATION
FUELS AS WE ALL KNOW WE ARE IN A
CLIMATE CRISIS AND DIESEL
CONTINUES TO DOMINATE THE HEAVY
DUTY TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
DIESEL POWERED HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
ARE THE SINGLE LARGEST SOURCE
OF. SMOG FORMING POLLUTION AND
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE WE CERTAINLY NEED
MORE POLICY TOOLS IN ORDER TO
HELP SUPPORT THE DECARBONISATION
OF FUELS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN WOULD COMPLEMENT OUR
EXISTING LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD BY OFFERING ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM HIGH CARBON FUELS I'M
NOW PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES A BILL
MCGOVERN MCGOVERN FROM THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. AND
PATRICK CANNING FROM THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS. THANKS VERY MUCH MANAGER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
IN SUPPORT- IT AS THE AUTHOR
STATED TRANSPORTATION IS THE
BIGGEST SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION
AND CLIMATE. CAUSING EMISSIONS
IN CALIFORNIA AND- WE TALK IN
REDUCING TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS WE TALK ABOUT THREE.
VARIOUS WAYS TO DO IT ONE IS TO
CLEAN UP THE ENGINES IN THE
VEHICLES ANOTHER IS TO REDUCE
THE MILES TRAVELED BY THE
VEHICLES. AND THE OTHER ONE
WHICH THIS BILL ADDRESSES IS TO
CLEAN UP THE FUELS IN OUR
VEHICLES AND CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
A LEADER IN DOING THAT- AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED WE HAVE THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD WHICH IS
STARTING TO HAVE SOME MAJOR
SUCCESS. IN INTRODUCING
ALTERNATIVES TO PETROLEUM BASED
FUELS AND THIS BILL AS SHE SAID
WOULD REALLY BUILD ON THAT
SUCCESS AND USE THAT STANDARD AS
A METRIC. TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE NEED TO DO
MORE EVEN THOUGH YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE DOING MORE THAN OTHER
STATES RIGHT NOW STILL NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE CRISES
PRESENTED BY BOTH AIR POLLUTION.
AND CLIMATE CHANGE SO THIS BILL
I THINK TAKES A VERY SENSIBLE
APPROACH IN INCENTIVIZING THE
VERY CLEANEST LOW CARBON FUELS
FOR SIX YEARS SO WILL HAVE A
TRANSITION UNDER WAY TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND MY
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATES FOR THAT
ALL THE TIME BUT WE KNOW THAT
WHILE THE TRANSITION IS UNDER
WAY. WE WILL HAVE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF VEHICLES ON OUR
ROADS BURNING COMBUSTION FUELS
AND WE WANT THOSE FUELS TO BE AS
CLEAN AS POSSIBLE THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HOW TO GET IN
WITH THE COALITION FOR RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
MADE UP OF CITIES COUNTIES.
UNIVERSITIES LABOR UNIONS AND
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE FOR- MORE
THAN 95% OF THE RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS IN THE UNITED
STATES- CALIFORNIA'S BAN A WORLD
LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
VICTIM TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WHETHER IT'S DROUGHTS
WILDFIRES TO CONTINUE ABOVE
AVERAGE TEMPERATURE- IN OUR
STATE- AND WE KEEP TACKLING THIS
ISSUE HEAD ON BY COMMITTING TO
REDUCING NATURAL GAS TO
REMISSIONS. COSTLY SEEKING NEW
WAYS IN LARGE PART THIS BILL IS-
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN IS A
RESPONSE TO- THE SPEAKERS CALLED
THE PROTON THE GOVERNOR ALL
SAYING THAT WE NEED TO. DOUBLE
DOWN AND PUT MORE RESOURCE- TO
COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE AND OUR
STATE- AND IN OUR COUNTRY. FOR
THESE REASONS AND OTHERS WERE
FULL SUPPORT OF TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK. RIGHT TO US
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON TODD
CAMPBELL REPRESENTING THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHESTER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN KENNY WITH
CLEAN ENERGY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. PAUL WOODS WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF BIOENERGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT-
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT. SO IN THE
ANALYSIS- IT SAYS THAT THEY
DON'T THINK THERE'S REALLY A
SHORTAGE OF SUPPLIERS SURGED
PORTAGE SHORTAGE OF USERS. SO
WHY AND THAT MOST OF THE RESULT
OF THIS WILL GO TO CURRENT
SUPPLIERS. THIS DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE TO ME. ARM I COULD
SEE A GRANT PROGRAM. TO GET
MAYBE NEW SUPPLIERS ON IF
THERE'S SOME BARRIER TO ENTRY
AND THERE'S EVIDENCE OF THAT-
MIGHT MAKE MORE SENSE TO SIMPLY
DO SUBSIDIZE THE- PURCHASE OF-
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY VEHICLES. SO
WHY USE THIS APPROACH. AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT THAT QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AT SU THE
AS PRIMARY DRIVER FOR WHY DIESEL
REMAINS THE DOMINANT FUEL IN THE
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION FACTS
SECTOR IS COST AND THE REALITY
IS WE ARE NOT EVER GOING TO GET
TO A POINT WHERE. THESE FIVE IT
CLEANER FUELS ARE COST NEUTRAL
WITH DIESEL WE'RE JUST NOT AND
SO BY PROVIDING THIS AS AN
INCENTIVE TO SUPPLIERS THE
EXPECTATION AND THE GOAL IS IT
THEN THAT CAN CREATE MORE ELEVEN
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WITH THE
PRICING OF DIESEL AND THAT. IF
YOU SAID THAT THE IF THE
CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW IS WITH
DEMAND WE'VE GOT TO MANAGE TO
LOWER THE PRICE FOR THESE FUEL
SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY BE
COST COMPETITIVE WITH DIESEL AND
WELCOME WITH MY WHAT ABOUT WHEN
AT ANYTHING TO THAT- LET ME JUST
SAY. GANYMEDE ANALYSIS PRICES
SET BY SUPPLY AND DEMAND. WE'VE
DISCUSSED FOR EXAMPLE SUSPENDING
THE GAS TAX AND PEOPLE SAID.
WHO'S YOU KNOW PRICES SET BY
SUPPLY AND DEMAND THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE FIVE A HYDROGEN
VEHICLE. AND AS A CUSTOMER R. I
GET A DIRECT BENEFIT ACTUALLY
FULL FUEL IS FREE BUT ONE CAN
IMAGINE A CASE. WHERE ARM YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT FREE BUT IT'S AT A
REDUCED PRICE BUT AGAIN I'M
VERY. SKEPTICAL THAT THE PRICE
WILL ACTUALLY CHANGE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GIVING MONEY TO THE
PRODUCERS BECAUSE IT'S THE PRICE
IS NOT BASED ON PRODUCTION COST.
BASED ON SUPPLY AND DEMAND
THAT'S WEIGHED MARKETS WORK
THAT'S FRESHMAN ECONOMICS IN
COLLEGE. CORRECT THOUGH IN THIS
CASE IT I GUESS THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I DEMAND IS. IS AS
LOW AS IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
PRICE SO IN ORDER TO IMPACT. THE
PAST DEMAND SIDE WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE PRICE ELEMENT AND I
THINK THAT- I THINK THAT THE
REALITY AS WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS
OUR- GOAL OF CARBON NEUTRALITY
HERE IN THE STATE AND ALL AND
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IS THAT
AS WE ARE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS
HERE IS CALIFORNIA. UP ON
LOWERING DEMAND FOR GAS THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOOD BECAUSE- THE PRICE
POINT OF THESE LOWER CAR OF
THESE HIGHER CARBON FUELS TO
ACTUALLY GO DOWN AND SO WE HAVE
TO FIND SOME WAYS TO IMPACT THAT
IF WE ACTUALLY WANT. TO THEN BE
ABLE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON KIND
OF A GLOBAL SCALE MY ARGUMENT IS
A BONY IMPACTED BECAUSE THE
PRICE IS GOING TO BE SPENT BY
APPLIANCE SUPPLY AND DEMAND. SO
WAY IT'S ALWAYS SAID. UNLESS YOU
MAKE A DIFFERENT KIND OF MARKET
INTERVENTION THIS ISN'T GOING TO
WORK. THAT'S MY AND THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE ANALYSIS
SAYS IN THAT SECTION. ASSEMBLY
MAN I WOULD JUST ADD YOU KNOW
PARTICULAR YOURSELF WITH A
HYDROGEN CAR WE HAVE AN
ABUNDANCE OF HYDROGEN THE COST
FOR HYDROGEN IS ACTUALLY IN THE
ROOM THE- TECHNOLOGY THE
INNOVATION THAT COMES IN THE
LARGE PART. WITH THIS BILL WILL
DO IS HELP INCENTIVIZE THAT
INNOVATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO GET THE FUEL SOURCE
DIFFERENT FROM. SOME OF THE FUEL
SOURCES THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE ON
MORE OF A SCARCITY MODEL AS YOU
TALK ABOUT. THINGS LIKE HYDROGEN
THINGS LIKE SOME OF THESE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUELS- RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS THE PROBLEM WITH
HYDROGEN IS THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
SUPPLY. AND THE BEST WAY TO
SOLVE THAT WOULD BE FOR THE
STATE TO INVEST IN GETTING A
LARGER SUPPLY WHICH WOULD THEN
BRING DOWN THE PRICE. BUT JUST
GIVING MONEY TO PRODUCERS I
DON'T THINK CHANGES THE PRICE
THAT'S AGAIN THE ARGUMENT IN THE
ANALYSIS AND I AGREE WITH THAT.
THE BETTER THING TO DO IF
THERE'S REALLY IF IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE AND WHAT YOU WANT IS.
INNOVATION THEN SUBSIDIZE THE
INNOVATION. SUBSIDIZE SAY GOING
TO A LARGER SCALE THAT WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR HYDROGEN.
WHICH I KNOW QUITE WELL. THEIR
BIG PROBLEM IS YOU REALLY. HAVE
A HUGE CAPITAL INVESTMENT. YOU
CAN LOWER THE COST BY GOING TO
HIGHER SCALE SO IF YOU WANT TO
BRING DOWN THE PRICE OF HYDROGEN
IT WOULD BE TO SUBSIDIZE A VERY
LARGE PLANT WHICH COULD RUN
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. AND THUS GET
YOUR COMPLETE CAPITAL- PAID FOR
BECAUSE IT'S RUNNING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. THAT WOULD BE A WAY TO
REDUCE SUPPLIES HYDROGEN. GIVING
WE HAVE HAD THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THE HYDROGEN STATIONS COME HERE
REPEATEDLY TO ASK FOR TAX BREAK.
AND I'VE OPPOSED IT. I'M SORRY
THIS IS JUST ISN'T GOING TO
WORK. AND UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
THAT'S THE SAME WITH THIS. RIGHT
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OF THE I
WILL JUST ASK YOU TO HOLD YOUR
CLOTHES FOR ONE MOMENT BEFORE AS
ANYBODY DASHES OUT SO WE CAN
HAVE THIS ISLAND IS A ROLL CALL
PLEASE IRWIN. HERE WHEN HERE
GREAT. GRAYSON. LEVINE MAYES
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR WORK
YEAH RIVAS SAID ARE TO HAVE A
QUORUM. ALL RIGHTS OF WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISS PETER NORRIS
. I YES I THINK YOU AS A MEMBER
CORK- ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND BEING ABLE
TO ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS
AROUND WHAT I THINK ARE SOME
VERY REAL CHALLENGES FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT- WE DO A VERY GOOD JOB HERE
AT SETTING VERY LOFTY. GOALS
WHEN IT COMES TO ADD CONFRONTING
THE CLIMATE CRISIS- AND THE
DEVIL CAN REALLY BE IN THE
DETAILS IN TERMS AS- EXECUTING
AGAINST THOSE GOALS AND I WOULD
SAY THAT. MY VIEW IS THAT WE THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE ARE GOING TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN THE
STATE IS WITH A LARGE VARIETY OF
POLICY INCENTIVES THAT WILL
ENABLE THE MARKET TO TRANSITION.
I TO OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE SO
UP WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND. ALL RIGHT. FOR THE
MOTION AND THE SECOND AND WHY
DON'T WE AND I DO OFF OF WOULD
LIKE TO SAY TO THERE'S GOING TO
BE FURTHER DISCUSSION BECAUSE-
THE MOTION IS- DO PASSED TO
TRANSPORTATION MS HIGHLAND CAN
YOU PLEASE TO THE LOCAL- WHEN.
I- WHEN I WHEN. WHEN I GRAY.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE LEVINE
LEVINE I AM MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
ALRIGHT QUIRK NOW RIVAS
SARAH FONG QUALITY. IT'S ON
COLLEGE. THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE
TO PLACE ON ON CALL US FIVE TO
ONE AS THE VOTE CURRENTLY AND-
THEN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ASK
FOR- TWENTY TO SIXTEEN WHICH IS
MY CAL ABLE BILL. ALL RIGHT-
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GRAYSON AND ON THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED WITH CORPORATIONS ASYLUM
TO THE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO
ONE SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN I A GREAT GRAYSON. GRAYSON
I LIVING LIVING ON A MAYES
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I LIKE WORK WORK I
RIVAS CERAKOTE. BILL OUT ALL
RIGHTS AND THAT BILL IS OUT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. THE
END. OF THEIR VOTE THEIR
PRESENTATION OF THOSE ARE VOTE
ONLY AT THE END HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE ME AND OKAY- I'M SORRY- YES
- ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO- IT
LOOKS LIKE YOUR WITNESSES ARE
HERE PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY OR- I THINK YOU MANAGER
PHIL I'M GONNA PRESENT AND I. AM
TERRIBLY SORRY ABOUT THE LATE BY
TIME I RAN TO THE ALL THE MY
OFFICE TO BETTER MYSELF AND RAN
BACK AS WE NOW KNOW THINKING
ABOUT A HALF AN HOUR- BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR LONG
AS THE PRESENT LOOK AT. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN THAT ELECT
LIFTED- MILLIONS OF CHILDREN OUT
OF POVERTY ACROSS UNITED STATES-
ENDED- AT THE END OF LAS YEAR
AND WHAT THAT RESULTED TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION. A CHILDREN NOW
FALLING INTO POVERTY IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE THE INABILITY OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ACT. ON
THE LARGEST ANTI POVERTY PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE HAD WHICH IS- THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT. HERE WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS THE ABILITY TO
INCREASE THE CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OPPORTUNITY BETWEEN THE AGES OF
SUCH. AS ZERO AND SEVENTEEN.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO AUGMENT
WHAT WE NOW HAVE THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT ONE. THOUSAND DOLLARS
BETWEEN ZERO. TO FIVE YEARS OLD-
BUT THIS REALLY WOULD BE A GAME
CHANGER BECAUSE WE'VE NOT HAD-
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION CHILDREN
FALL BACK INTO POVERTY FOR THOSE
FAMILIES WERE THIRTY THOUSAND-
ENVELOPE. AND IDA IN IN THE
INABILITY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO STEP UP- HIS WE
HAS HAD DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON
THOSE FAMILIES. ARE EARNING
THIRTY THOUSAND AND BELOW. I
CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS- AND HOW
GRATEFUL I AM FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO HEAR THIS- BECAUSE WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES KIDS WERE GOING TO
SLEEP HUNGRY NIGHT. AT THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN BELOW AND
THERE'S- A IN. IT DOES ALMOST.
NOTHING ANYBODY CAN DO WE CAN DO
TO HELP THEM EXCEPT FOR THE-
DOLLARS THAT NOW ARE NOT COMING
INTO FAMILIES AND TODAY ON TAX.
ON THE DAY THAT WE'RE FILING
TAXES I THINK IT'S- IT'S
IMPORTANT WE STRESS. HOW
FAMILIES COULD HAVE RECEIVED-
THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THERE
THAT ARE NOT. RECEIVING THIS
BILL ALSO. INCREASES THE KELETI
SEAT FOR THOSE WHO ARE OF FILING
THIRTY THOUSAND AND BELOW FROM A
TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD RANGE
ANYWHERE FROM A DOLLAR TO ABOUT
TWO FIFTY FIVE TWO. TO TWO FIFTY
FIVE AUTOMATICALLY NOT AN ICMA
NOT SEEM A LOT BUT WHEN YOU'RE
MAKING THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
BELOW TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
DOLLARS- IT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN EATING. AND NOT EATING.
MAN AND MANY MEMBERS ON
EXTREMELY GRAY FOR THE UP. TO
PRESENT- AND WOULD NOT HAVE OVER
TO TWO OF OUR- WITNESSES THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANA HOW SUPPLIED WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF
OF THE KELLY ATC COALITION WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE. THE
BILL DOES TWO THINGS IT MAKES
PERMANENT A PERMANENT CHANGE TO
THE KELLY ATC FOR THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ENSURING THEY GET A MEANINGFUL
CREDIT OF AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS. AND IT
STEPS UP WITH THE TARGETED
SOLUTION FOR PRESSING CRISIS IN
OUR STATE CHILD POVERTY FIRST ON
THE MINIMUM CAL THE ATC ABOUT
HALF OF WORKERS WITHOUT CHILDREN
IN THE HOME RECEIVE AND KELLY I
TO SEE OF UNDER A HUNDRED
DOLLARS. AND MOST OF THEM ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE FEDERAL EITC
ON TOP OF THIS MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH CHILDREN ALSO
RECEIVE A KELLY ATC OF LESS THAN
A HUNDRED DOLLARS. RESEARCH
PROVE PROVE THAT TAX CREDITS ARE
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS
OF DEFEATING POVERTY AND WE HAVE
SEEN THIS RECENTLY. LAST YEAR
THE EXPANDED FEDERAL CHILD TAX
CREDIT CUT CHILD POVERTY BY 33%
IN CALIFORNIA. DATA SHOWED THIS
LEAD TO GREATER FOOD SECURITY%
HOUSING STABILITY. BETTER JOBS
AND LESS STRESS IN FAMILIES WITH
KIDS. NOW THE EXPANDED CDC HAS
EXPIRED ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
CHILDREN ARE FALLING BACK INTO
POVERTY RIGHT NOW ON OUR WATCH.
IN JANUARY THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN IN POVERTY SPIKE
DRAMATICALLY WITH BLACK AND
LATINO CHILDREN SEEING THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE INCREASE. AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE PER
CHILD TAX CREDIT PAYMENT. IS THE
MOST TARGETED AND EFFECTIVE WAY
TO MEET SEVERAL GOALS. REDUCE
POVERTY HOPE FAMILIES DEALING-WITH INFLATION. BOOSTS LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND IMPROVE LIFELONG
RESULTS FOR CHILDREN. TAKEN
TOGETHER WITH THE KELLY ATC
MINIMUM. THIS IS A RARE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A BIG DOWN
PAYMENT ON THE FUTURE PROSPERITY
WILL MEET IN THE PRESSING NEEDS
OF CHILDREN RIGHT NOW. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE WHAT CODY
SHARES NEXT AND APPLY THAT TO
WELL OVER TWO MILLION CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT SO MANY CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE ARE EXPERIENCING SUCH
HARDSHIP. BUT WE CAN ACT TO
CHANGE THIS. SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU
WHEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACT TO VOTE BY ON A B. TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU.
HELLO TEARING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CODY EVAN FELLED AND I'M TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD AND LIVING IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. IT IS MY HONOR TO
SPEAK IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY ON
WHY SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO. I HAD MY DAUGHTER IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT WAS
A VERY HIGH RISK PREGNANCY WHICH
CREATED A LOT OF ANXIETY.
BECAUSE I WAS VISITING THE
DOCTOR SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK
INCREASING MY CHANCES OF
CONTRACTING COVERT NINETEEN. I
LOST HOURS AT WORK BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC PUT THE WORLD ON HOLD.
I LEARNED VERY QUICKLY HOW
EXPENSIVE HAVING A CHILD COULD
BE. I QUALIFIED FOR THE FEDRAL
ADVANCE CHILD TAX CREDITS BUT I
HAD ALREADY FILED MY TAXES
BEFORE MY CHILD WAS BORN. I
CHECKED WEEKLY FOR THE UPDATED
PORTAL TO BE AVAILABLE BUT IT
NEVER WAS. IN FACT I ONLY JUST
RECEIVED MY CHILD TAX CREDIT
REFUND A WEEK AGO ON APRIL
TWELFTH. I WENT THROUGH ALL OF
MY SCHOOL SAVINGS TO JUST TO
CARE FOR MY CHILD BECAUSE I
NEVER RECEIVED THE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS. KEEP IN MIND ON
AVERAGE FOR SIX MONTHS FOR
FORMULA DIAPERS AND WIPES I
COULD SPEND ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS. THIS
COST DOES NOT INCLUDE. INCLUDE
ITEMS NEEDED FOR OTHER HEALTH
AND HYGIENE ESSENTIALS SAFETY
EQUIPMENT REQUIRED FROM MY HOME.
SENSORY STIMULATION
SOCIALIZATION IN PLAY AND RIGHT
NOW DAY CARES TOO EXPENSIVE.
RECEIVING A CHURCH CALIFORNIA
CHILD TAX CREDIT PAYMENT AS
OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE WOULD ALLOW MY
DAUGHTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SOCIALIZE WITH CHILDREN HER OWN
AGE. I WOULD ALSO HAVE THE
CHANCE TO PURCHASE TOYS TO HELP
MY DAUGHTER THRIVE WITH
STIMULATION TO REACH ALL OF HER
DEVELOPMENTAL MILESTONES. THIS
MONEY WOULD GIVE THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES AND ME THE SUPPORT.
THEY NEED TO TRANSITION FROM THE
EXPERIENCES FACED BY THE
PANDEMIC SOCIETY'S EXPECTATION
OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT IS A STRONG
INFLUENCER. AS A MOTHER IT IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE ALL
NECESSARY ELEMENTS TO ENSURE SHE
THRIVES. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE WOULD HELP ME FULFILL MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS I PURSUE MY
EDUCATION AND BUILD A BETTER
FUTURE FOR US. I ASK YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND
LISTEN TO MY STORY. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. YOU SENATE JIMENEZ
POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH GRACE AND
CHAKAVIAN CALIFORNIA AND MANAGER
MAY ALSO READ THE NEAT LISTS OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WANTED TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT OKAY GREAT OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
SAN DIEGO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
COALITION AND POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN AS EPIC
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON HERE
REPRESENTING THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION WHICH IS
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL. ALSO
URGING SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OUR RIGHTS OF THE
THEM I JUST WANT TO COMMENT THAT
THE WHAT WE KNOW TODAY WE. BY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE-
CREDIT ENHANCEMENTS WILL BE
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE SO- WE WILL BE
TAKING A VOTE ON THIS AT A LATER
TIME BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I
THANK MR SANTIAGO ALL RIGHT FILE
ITEM SIX US AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF
YOU'RE PUT OFF.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
FURTHER. MANY SUGGESTIONS. TO
MAKE THIS BILL EVEN BETTER. WITH
THAT. WE WILL BE SUBMITTING THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT WILL MAKE THE
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL EFFECTIVELY AND I. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY SIXTY ADDRESS THE IMPACT
OF THE CURRENT GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS IS HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA EXPERTS. AND HELP OUR
FARMERS AND MANUFACTURERS ACCESS
FOREIGN MARKETS. OUR FARMERS ARE
FINDING IT HARDER TO COME
COMPETE IN A GLOBAL MARKETPLACE-
PLAYED BY HIGHER COST AND THE
LACK OF THE BILL AVAILABILITY OF
IN TRAIN THE MODEL EQUIPMENT. MY
DISTRICT IS HIT DOUBLE DOUBLE
THE HARD BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING
THE EFFECTS OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS FIRSTHAND AS THE PORT OF
STOCKTON. WHICH IS A STRAINING
ITS TRAINING UNDER THE
ADDITIONAL DEMANDS THAT ARE
BEING PUT ON THE DOCKS SHIPS IN
LONG SURE LABOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES AND HELP
CALIFORNIA EXPERTS EXPORTS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT. IN TWO WAYS FIRST
AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN
WILL ESTABLISH THE EXPORT CARGO
TAX CREDIT. AND SECOND AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY WILL ALSO
ESTABLISH A COMPLIMENTARY CREDIT
SPECIFICALLY FOR EXPORT
EQUIPMENT ACCESS CREDIT. JOINING
ME TODAY. IS OUR MIKE JACOB OF
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION AND MARTHA MILLER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PORT AUTHORITIES TO PROVIDED
TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AND MEMBERS MIGHT TAKE UP
WITH PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION- AND- OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE WE'RE HERE- AGAIN WE'VE
BEEN HERE- EARLIER IN THE
SESSION- TO DISCUSS SUPPLY
CHAIN- CHALLENGES WE'VE BEEN
HAVING. AND A TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF WAYS WE
CAN HELP CREATE MORE FLUIDITY
OUR INTERMODAL SYSTEM- WITH-
PACKAGE OF BILLS- YOU SAW ONE
FROM MISTER DONALD THIS ONE'S
WITH MR VIA PADILLA- TRYING TO
GET A BOTH SIDES OF THE COIN-
WE'RE- REALLY DESPERATELY TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE. NOT ONLY
ACCESS TO MARKETS- FOR IMPORTERS
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR EQUIPMENT
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- BUT
ALSO FOR EXPORTERS WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR ACCESS BOTH THE
VESSELS AND TO THE EQUIPMENT
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO GET THAT-
PRODUCT SUPPORT- AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE. A SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS
WHOSE HALLMARK IS- A LACK OF
SUPPLY OF INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT
AND SPACE ON TERMINAL- AND THAT
DRIVES UP THE COST OF DRUGS OF
DELAY IN INEFFICIENCY- AND THOSE
ARE PASSED ALONG TO CALIFORNIA
EXPORTERS SO THERE'S- TWO
DIFFERENT CREDITS IN THIS BILL
THEY'RE BOTH INTEND TO ADDRESS
THE- IMPACTS OF THOSE COSTS. ON
OUR EXPORTS COMMUNITIES- AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO
WHAT OUR MEMBERS DO WITCHES AND
PROCESS THOSE GOODS ACROSS
DOCKING ON THE VESSELS- HAPPEN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND- ALSO
THANK YOU AS MR. PEROT SAID TO
THE STAFF FOR WORKING VERY CLOSE
WITH US ON ON THE SERVE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AND ME. AND
THE CONSULTANTS REPORT THANK YOU
. MARTHA NOT HELP AS- MARTHA MAY
HERE BEHALF OF THE CONFERENCES
ASIA PER OF THIRTY- MANY OF YOU
HAVE PARTS IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
YOU UNDERSTAND THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO COME UP WITH PROACTIVE
SOLUTIONS- THIS IS WHY WE'RE
DOING IT INVESTMENT M. AND
CREDIT- SPECIFICALLY FOR AG
EXPERT COMMUNITY- THE ELEVEN CAP
UPWARDS REPRESENT 30% OF ALL
CONTAINERIZED IMPORTS IN ABOUT
20% OF THE EXPERTS UNITED
STATES. WE IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
WE- ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT THREE
POINT ONE MILLION JOBS- THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BY TRADE MOVING
THROUGH OUR PORTS. AT AND SO
IT'S HUGELY IMPERATIVE THAT WE
TRY TO TACKLE THESE ISSUES AND
WE DO HAVE. A PACKAGE OF BILLS
ARE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW BUT WE
UNDERSTAND CAME OVER THE LAST
DECADE EXACERBATED BY. THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CHANGES IN
CONSUMER SPENDING HABITS- THIS
IS BANNED REALLY I'M ACUTELY
FELT BUYER CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTERS- AND SO
FOR US. THAT'S A HUGE IMPORTANT-
PIECE THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
INCENTIVES AND GETTING
INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CONGESTION
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. IS
NOT ALLOWING FOR THE EXPERT
COMMUNITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CHAIN MANY CONTAINERS- AND
DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT ARE. BEING
SHIPPED RIGHT BACK TO ASIA AND
OTHER PLACES BECAUSE IT'S JUST
CHEAPER AND MORE EFFICIENT TO DO
THAT. SO THIS BILL CREATES TO
TAX CREDITS TO INCENTIVIZE I GOT
EXPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING AT THE CARGO CREDIT
FOR ADDITIONAL TONNAGE BEING
EXPORTED AND A TAX CREDIT FOR
THE MOVE OF INTERMODAL EQUIPMENT
FROM STORAGE TO AN EXPORTER. SO
WE THINK THAT'S REALLY GONNA
HELP THE EXPORTERS ARE KIND OF
DIFFERENT THE COSTS AND INCREASE
THEIR CAPACITY. SO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PORT COMMUNITY
YOU KNOW OUR EXPERT COMMUNITY IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AND IT'S
A PRIORITY AND WE THINK THIS
BILL WOULD REALLY HELP WITH THE
CONGESTION CURRENTLY. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU PRESTON YOUNG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT MR- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SO WHAT SORT OF CHANGES HERE ARE
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERING. RATHER THAN THE
DOLLAR FIFTY PER YEAH THANK YOU
MR QUIRK- SO IT IN THE ANALYSIS
YOU'LL NOTE THAT THERE IS A
REFERENCE WITH RESPECT TO THE
RETROACTIVITY OF THE CREDIT
SERVICES PROPOSED THAT'S BEING
REMOVED- THERE'S ALSO REFERENCE
TO- THE- I'M SORRY I HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATOR IT'S A- BIT
CARRYOVERS AND THE- DOLLARS ACTS
BENEFIT THAT'S RIGHT THERE'S A
THERE'S A CARRYOVER PROVISION
WHICH WAS. UNLIMITED AND NOW
IT'S GOING TO BE LIMITED TO TWO
EIGHT YEARS AS PROPOSED BY F.
TV- AND THEN ON THE- CHANGE WITH
RESPECT TO DEDUCTIBILITY VERSES
THE CREDIT. THAT'S GOING TO BE
LIMITED AS WELL SO NO DEDUCTION
WILL BE ALLOWED FOR EXPENSES
WHEN THE VALUE EXPENSES WAS
INCLUDED IN THE CREDIT VALUE
OKAY BUT HOW IS THIS GOING TO
HELP. EVERYBODY GETS A DOLLAR
FIFTY PER DELIVERY AND YOU KNOW.
YOU'VE YOU'VE TRIED THE
REQUIREMENTS ON IT THAT'S FINE
BUT HOW DOES THIS REALLY HELP US
BUILD UP OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH I BE BETTER OFF SPENDING
THAT MONEY JUST BUYING MORE
CONTAINERS. FOR USE IN THE
PORTS- SUBSIDIZING THAT WAY
RATHER THAN. I MEAN THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE. WHAT HAPPENS THAT
DOLLAR FIFTY. RIGHT AND THERE'S
TWO COMPONENTS THAT I'M I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP THE EQUIPMENT
SIDE THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT THROUGH A SEPARATE
TAX CREDIT THAT'S MISTRUST
ALMOST TAX CREDIT PROPOSAL- ON
THIS ONE VERY SPECIFIC WHEN THE
DOLLAR FIFTY THAT'S NOT
CONTAINER SPECIFIC THAT'S ON
TONNAGE- AND SO THAT'S INTENDED
TO HELP. DEFRAY THE FOCUS OF ALL
OF THIS TONNAGE IN OUR CONTAINER
COMMUNITY. MAKE IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE FOR PORTS LIKE. THE
PORT OF STOCKTON- PORT HUENEME
ME PORTS INDIGO THAT AREN'T
CONTAINERIZED FOCUS BUT PROVIDE
MORE ACCESS AND AN INTERMODAL
OPPORTUNITY THOUGH I SEE YOU'RE
NOT CONTAINER. THERE'S A SECOND
COMPONENT OF THIS WHICH IS THE
SECOND ONE IS SPECIFIC TO
CONTAINER ACCESS LAWS- AND- BUT
THAT DOLLAR FIFTY PER TONNAGE IS
ONLY BASED ON YOUR ADDITIONAL
TIME SO YOU DON'T GET PAID FOR
YOUR BASELINE TONNAGE. YOU ONLY
GET PAID FOR THE ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT OVER THE PRIOR YEAR- AND
SO IS INTENDED TO ONLY OFFSET-
SO IT'S REDUCING THE COSTS FOR
WHO THE PORT FOR THE ACTUAL
EXPORTER THE ACTUAL EXPORTER THE
CARGO HONOR SO. WHAT HAPPENS SO
BASICALLY STOCKTON ISN'T
COMPETITIVE. IS THAT THE
PROBLEM. STOCKTON IS VERY
COMPETITIVE- FOR THE CARGOES
THAT STOCKTON HAS ALWAYS BEEN
COMPETITIVE FOR. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY COST COMPETITIVE
COMPARED TO THE CONTAINERIZED
EXPORT TRADE RIGHT- AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS BROUGHT IN
THE- THE ACTUAL BASE. SO YOU'RE
OUT OF THE VERYPLACE WHERE A
LOT OF EXPORTERS FIND THEMSELVES. NOW WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
OPTIONS- AND- THIS THAT'S ONE
COMPONENT OF IT. THE OTHER
COMPONENT OF IT OF ACCESS IS THE
SECOND ONE WHICH IS WE HAVE A
GLUT OF EMPTY CONTAINERS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT. AND
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH INTO
CONTAINERS IN PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE WANT TO EXPORT WITH THEM
PRIMARILY IN CENTRAL AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE ACTUAL
REPOSITIONING COSTS TO GET A
QUICK MEN OUT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA INTO CENTRAL VALLEY
IS A NEW COSTS THAT WAS NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR BY PEOPLE PREPEND
EMIC I'D ALWAYS HAD A- A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT AND
CONTAINERS AVAILABLE. YOU COULD
PICK ONE UP ANYONE TIME YOU
WANTED- IT WAS NOT VERY COSTLY.
NOW THEY'RE VERY COSTL THEY'RE
OUT OF POSITION AND EVEN THE
COST OF THE ACTUAL
TRANSPORTATION HIGHER SO
THERE'S- MORE DEMAND FOR
TRUCKING ALL OF THAT- ASSOCIATED
WITH IT SO THE SO THIS WOULD BE
BASICALLY SUBSIDIZE SUBSIDY FOR
BRINGING CONTAINERS FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN YEAH ANY OF THOSE
REPOSITIONING IS BUT THAT'S THE
PRIMARY ONE. OKAY AND THAT WOULD
BE ENOUGH TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THE DOLLAR FIFTY. WE LOVE THAT
BACK CREDIT IS KEEN ON A THIRTY
DOLLAR MOVE WE ACTUALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL HELP-
OFFSET SOME OF THOSE COSTS- THAT
THE TRUCKING MARKET IS YOU KNOW
IS VERY VOLATILE SPOT PRICES ARE
ALL OVER THE PLACE- BUT- WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE MARKETPLACE ITSELF
WHAT WE DID WAS WE- CAME TO
THAT. DOLLAR FIGURE- BY
ESTIMATING HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT MIGHT
POTENTIALLY HAVE AVAILABLE
WITHIN THE THRESHOLD- WE SET A
THRESHOLD IN THIS BILL SO THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CHANGE THAT-
DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
THAT'S ONE OF THE CONTROLS IN
HERE TOO THAT IT'S LIMITED BY
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
APPROPRIATED IN THE BILL OR NOW
I UNDERSTAND A LOT BETTER. ARM
SO THE CONTAINERS ARE BEING
MOVED UP HOW WOULD THIS AFFECT
US SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OAKLAND. WHAT PRIMARILY ON THE
EXPORT SIDE- WE BELIEVE THAT IT
WOULD IT WOULD BENEFIT OAKLAND-
STOCKTON AND- WHERE SACRAMENTO-
WITH RESPECT TO AGRICULTURAL
EXPORTS ON WITH RESPECT TO
MANUFACTURING EXPORTS WE THINK
THAT IT WOULDN'T WOULD AFFECT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PORTS
PRIMARILY- BUT- YOU KNOW IF YOU
WANNA SPEAK A LITTLE BIT SIR TO.
I THINK UNDER. THE IN THE DAY
WHEN I CAN BE SUPPORT OR NOT
WE'RE NOT COMPETING AGAINST EACH
OTHER OKAY I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
THAT TO OCCUR. I AM I CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE YEAH I THINK YOU
IT'S GOOD TO SEE ALL OF THE U.
S. SEVENTY. IN YEARS SO IT'S
NICE TO HAVE YOU GUYS UP HERE-
AND DESCRIBING SOME OF THAT I'M
I'M HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU KNOW MY MIDDLE SCHOOL YOU
KNOW DAUGHTER AOUT SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES- EVERYONE IS HYPER AWARE
OF THIS. AND I THINK WHAT WE
STRUGGLE WITH IS LIKE THE SCALE
OF THIS AND I THINK DOCTOR COURT
GRAYSON INTERESTING ISSUE ABOUT
OKAY IT'S A DOLLAR FIFTY PER
MOVE. HOW MANY OF THESE MOVES
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THIS
CHALLENGE WHAT WHAT DOES IT LOOK
LIKE WHAT WHAT ARE WE KIND OF
PROJECTING OUT- THE CHALLENGE OF
MOVING THESE GOODS WILL BE ART
pTHAT THIS ACTUALLY DOES MAKE AN
IMPACT WE DON'T DO IT JUST TO DO
IT WE WANTED RIGHT. UNDERSTAND
THAT RIGHT NOW YEAH IF WE'RE
TRYING TO REALLY VISUALIZE THE
SCALE- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MILLIONS OF TRANSACTIONS- BUT TO
MAKE THAT. TANGIBLE FOR YOU KNOW
TO ACTUALLY BREAK I DOWN TO
WHAT WHAT WHAT YOU ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE CREDIT FOR AN BE
PROVIDED ON VALUE. OR ON THE
ACTUAL WEIGHT OF THE GOODS
BECAUSE OF THE TWO THINGS THAT
YOU POTENTIALLY. ARE ALWAYS
KEEPING TRACK OF- OUTSIDE WITH
THE TRANSACTION ITSELF- AND SO
ON THE TONNAGE SCALE YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO ENVISION WHAT
WE WANT WITH THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
OF. OF WAIT THE YOU COULD FIT IN
ONE CONTAINER- YOU KNOW THE
WEIGHT SCALE IS UP TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND. POUNDS- BUT NOT ALL
THAT IS A NEW- AND SO WHAT WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE IS THAT
YOU'RE ONLY GETTING CREDIT FOR
THE ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OVER YOUR
BASE LINE CREDIT- THE CHALLENGE
OBVIOUSLY IS YOU DON'T WANT TO
PAY SOMEONE TO DO SOMETHING
THROUGH A CREDIT FOR SOMETHING
THEY WERE GOING TO DO ANYWAYS-
BUT YOU DO WANT TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE FOR YOU TO INCREASE
THAT- SO IF YOU'RE TALKING.
ABOUT A FAMILY FARM. THAT'S
USUALLY DOING TWO HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED CONTAINERS- YOU
KNOW THAT'S A LOT THAT'S A LOT
OF CONTAINERS- AND- SO IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO DO. 5% 10% MORE OF THIS
YOU'RE TALKING. ANALYSIS OF
VALUE TO ACTUALLY OFFSET THE
COST OF THE ADDITIONAL
LOGISTICS- AND HIRING ADDITIONAL
TRUCKERS. ADDITIONAL CONTAINERS
MOVING THOSE THINGS IN THE PLAN
SO WOULD YOU. YOU KNOW TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE A SENSE OF HOW MANY
CONTAINERS ARE WE RE POSITIONING
THAT WE WERE IN OTHERWISE
REPOSITIONING GIVEN. THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN AND- JUST THE
DEMAND ON ON GOOD SIDE. THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT NATURALLY JUST
AVAILABLE FOR US YEAH- SO
OVERALL WE'RE WE- THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC WE WERE JUST SHY OF 20%
MORE CONTAINERS MOVING THROUGH
OUR OUR MAIN TRADE GATEWAYS IN
LA LONG BEACH. WHICH MEANS THAT
WE HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE 20% MORE
CONTAINERS GOING BACK TO ASIA.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S CREATING A LOT
OF OUR CONGESTION- AND ON THE
IMPORT SIDE THAT CROWDS OUT
IMPORTS- AND SO OUR TOTAL INPUT
IMPORT VALUES HAVE BEEN
DECREASING AS ARE EXPLORED.
EMPTY LOADS HAVE BEEN GOING UP-
BUT THAT'S ABOUT 20% HIGHER. HOW
MANY CONTAINERS IS 20% HIGHER.
IT'S ABOUT TWO MILLION AND LA
IT'S ABOUT TWO MILLION IN LONG
BEACH- SO WE WE'VE NEVER BEEN
BUSIER WHERE WE'RE MOVING ABOUT
FOUR MILLION MORE TO USE THAN WE
TYPICALLY WOULD- AND- SO IT'S
SUBSTANTIAL YEAH ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT. RIGHT A
MISTER VEHICLE WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. SPECT GAS FOR NAY
VOTE ALL RIGHT AND- THIS IS OF
COURSE- FOR A HEARING ONLY AND
SO- I'M SURE EVERYBODY WILL
REMEMBER WHEN IT'S TIME TO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN- I
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. UP AGAIN FOR AYE-
FILE ITEM. SEVEN TWENTY SIX
FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THAT
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MEMBERS
HAPPY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SIX FIVE ONE THIS BILL
SUPPORTS OUR STATE'S EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SENATOR BELL PASSED A
BILL TO EXEMPT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS FROM PROPERTY TAXES. IF
THE DEVELOPMENT WILL SUPPLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS WAS A
REALLY INNOVATIVE IDEA AT THE
TIME AND WAS PASSED INTO LAW
WITH A SUNSET IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE INITIAL RESULTS HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING AND THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE SUNSET AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS TO TWENTY
THIRTY SO THAT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS CAN. CONTINUE TO UTILIZE
THIS EXEMPTION AND CONTINUE TO
ACCUMULATE MORE DATA
DEMONSTRATING THE EFFICACY OF
THIS LAW AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO STRUGGLE WITH THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I BELIEVE WE
NEED TO PURSUE ANY AVENUE WE CAN
TO MEET THIS NEED. AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY ONE SUPPORTS THIS EFFORT
OP PLEASE BE JOINED TODAY BY
PAUL CAN SOLVE THIS WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE IRVINE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BARGAINS ALL THIS ON
THE HAVE THE RIGHT COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST AND THANK YOU A
SMOOTHER PETRIE-NORRIS FOR
LEADING US ON THIS ISSUE- MY
CLIENT THE KERR THE- THE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OF IRVINE
THEY- THEY WERE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THIS FURTHER. CURRENT PROJECTS
SAGE PARK WHICH IS A SIXTY EIGHT
UNIT- AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
FOR SALE PROJECT THERE ARE SIX
THOUSAND APPLICANTS FOR THE FOR
THIS ONE HOUSING PROJECT SO THE
DEMAND IS THERE THE DEMAND WAS
SO HIGH THEY HAD TO DO A
LOTTERY. IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE TO
FIGURE OUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE THE LUCK TO GET
INTO ONE OF THESE HOMES SO THE
DEMAND IS REALLY HIGH
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL TOOK
EFFECT JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THREE MONTHS LATER
COVETED. AND NASH TOOK THAT
STOPPED EVERYBODY IN THEIR
TRACKS AND BECAUSE EVERYBODY TO
PUT EVERYTHING ON HOLD- THE
SUPPLY J. ISSUES THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE WAS MENTIONING
PRIOR IN THE PRIOR BILL. WAS
VERY MUCH A AFFECT FOR US THAT
CAUSES TO HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
TABLE AND RE EVALUATE WHETHER OR
NOT THESE. PROJECTS WERE GONNA
PENCIL OUT REMAIN AFFORDABLE-
WHAT WE WERE WE STILL HAVE A FEW
YEARS LEFT ON THE BOOKS BUT OUR
FINANCERS ARE LENDERS WANT TO
SEE MORE LONGEVITY THEY WANT TO
KNOW THAT. WHEN THEY'RE
INVESTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THESE PROJECTS. THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
STABILITY THERE. AND THEY WANT
TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THIS
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS GOING
GOING TO REMAIN. AND SO WE HAVE
A ANOTHER SEVEN ACRE PARCEL THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO GET STARTED ON
AND- JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IT'S GOING TO TAKE TWO
YEARS TO ADJUST THE PLANNING
PORTION BEFORE WE CAN EVEN GET
TO THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE AND
THEN ANOTHER TWO YEARS ON TOP OF
THAT. IF WE'RE LUCKY TO
CONSTRUCT ALL THESE PROJECTS-
THE WINTERS DON'T WANT TO END ON
IT BECAUSE OF THE WELFARE
EXEMPTION AND WHETHER I WAS
GOING TO BE IN QUESTION RIGHT
SO. FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
ASKING FOR A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
EXIT EXTENSION- NOT ONLY TO
PROVE THAT WE BELONG TO BE IN
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TOOLBOX
BUT WE SHOULD BE IN THE TOP
DRAWER OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TOOLBOX. SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
GOT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE- HELLO HONORABLE CHEERING
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS AMY HINES
SHAIKH WITH WILDCAT CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION OF TWENTY SIX
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENTING WELL
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
COMMUNITY ASSETS FOR PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND COMMUNITY
FACILITIES. HOUSING THOUSANDS OF
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. WHILE
OTHER FORMS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PLACE INCOME
RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR PROPERTIES
THAT EXPIRE AFTER SOME PERIOD OF
TIME OFTEN. APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
YEARS OR SO. CLT IS KEEP
PROPERTIES PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE THROUGH OUR NINETY
NINE YEAR GROUND LEASES WHILE
PROVIDING STABILITY TO
RESIDENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX FIFTY ONE WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET OF A BILL THAT'S BEEN A
MENTAL USEFUL TO US. SB ONE
NINETY SIX SPELL FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOTED- SB ONE NINETY SIX HAS
ALLOWED COMMUNITY LAND TRUST TO
BE EXEMPT FROM PROPERTY TAXES
WHILE OUR PROPERTIES ARE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION BEFORE. THEY BECOME
HABITABLE. WELL PROFIT DRIVEN
HOUSING DEVELOPERS CAN PAY
PROPERTY TAXES WHILE THEIR
PROPERTIES ARE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE THEY MAKE
UP THE LOSSES WHEN SELLING OR
LEASING THE RESIDENTS AT A
MARKET RATE. CLT IS ARE NOT ABLE
TO MAKE UP THE LOSSES BECAUSE
OUR RESIDENTS ARE LOW INCOME
AND- ALL UNITS. ARE TO ASSIST
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
RECEIVING STABLE HOMES WITH
DIGNITY. OF OUR TWENTY SIX
AFFILIATES MANY ARE CURRENTLY
USING SB ONE NINETY SIX TO MAKE
MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS PENCIL OUT.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
BOLINAS CLT. OAKLAND CLT. IRVINE
CLT THAT MISTER GRAHAM.
REPRESENTS AND PLANNED FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS INCLUDE WEST MARIN
CLT AND INLAND EQUITY C. L.
TEAM. THE FIVE YEAR EXTENSION OF
THE SUNSET OF SB ONE NINETY SIX
DELINEATED IN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY ONE IS CRITICAL TO
ASSISTING THE COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST MODEL GROW AND THRIVE. AND
WE APPLAUD THE VISIONARY
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS WE WERE. ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND JUST TO NOTE-
SB ONE NINETY SIX DEAD WE'RE
VERY PROUD THAT IT I ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO THANK YOU. ON. RIGHT- YOU HAD ANOTHER
BUILDING AND SEEING THAT. AND ON
YOUR MOBILE PHONE SO- AND THEN.
YEAH THE- ALL RIGHT. WHILE
YOU'RE THERE FOR AROUND IS- WE
DON'T WANT US TO THAT LINE. THE
WORLD WHERE. FOUR THE STUFF THAT. YES I CERTAINLY AWARE OF THAT
OF THAT FEEDBACK AND
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT CONCERN AND
CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT FIVE
PROGRAMS ARE ARE ANALYZED IN
EFFECT EFFICACY IS EVALUATED
BEFORE WE EXTEND AT PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS I THINK THAT THE
CHALLENGE IN THE CONUNDRUM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO WRAP OUR HEADS
AROUND IS JUST THE TIME HORIZON
THAT'S INVOLVED WITH PROJECTS
SUCH AS THIS AND AS OBSTACLE
BECAUSE- BOB POINTED OUT THAT
THE FACT THAT LENDERS ARE
LOOKING FOR MORE STABILITY IS
THEY'RE MAKING THEIR CHOICES SO-
I THINK OUR- OUR PUSH FOR A
SLIGHTLY LONGER EXTENSION IS
REALLY DRIVEN BY ENSURE WE ARE
GETTING KIND OF A CHICKEN AND
THE EGG. SITUATION WITH SO WE'LL
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING KNOWS THIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH. COMMITTEE
STAFF. YES INDEED INDEED. WELL I
THINK YOU AS I SAID WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING I HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AND
YOUR TEAMAND- WOULD FIVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO- ADD MEMBERS TO CALL
AND- THE PHONE CALL AND I WANT
TO. THANK ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GRAY. GREAT I MAYES. MOLEN
MULLIN I RIVAS RIVAS III
FAIRDALE IRAN AT TEN ON NINETY
ONE YEAH. ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP ARE THREE OF THOSE
ONLY ITEMS AND- WELL AS I ON ALL
OF THEM SO FIRST WE HAVE A FILE
ITEM EIGHT- AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN.
INTERMISSION AND WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. SECOND ALL
RIGHT SO THE MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS A SECOND FIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- LEVINE IN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A HUMAN
SERVICES MISSILE INCREASE THE
ROBOT WILL CALL AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO HUMAN SERVICES IRWIN. WHEN I
WHEN I WHEN I AGREE. GREAT I
GRAYSON. LEVINE LEVINE AYE MAYES
MULLIN MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK. RIVAS
RIVAS I SIERRA SIERRA THE BILL
HAS PASSED RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM
FOR VOTE ONLY IS FILE ITEM NINE
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AGREED TO THE
AMENDMENTS NOTED ON PAGE SEVEN
OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH AT A
SUNSET DATE AND REMOVE THIS
BILLS APPLICATION TO MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING- WOULD THANK HER
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
WITH THAT DO I HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND. SECOND ALL RIGHT-
THE MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE NORRIS OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS
HIGHLAND PLACE TO THE LOCAL.
IRWIN HI- WHEN I WHEN. FIVE WHEN
I GREAT. GRAYSON. GRAYSON NOT
VOTING GRAY NOT VOTING. GREAT
NOT VOTING ARI LEVINE LEVINE I
MAYES MULLIN MULLIN I'D
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK RIVAS REALLY SORRY SERRA
SERRA. SIX SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN TO
ONE IT'S PAST AND THAT BILL IS
ABOUT FINALLY- FINALLY TO SPEND
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY BY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND I WILL
NOTE ON THAT THAT- FIFTY REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION ONCE THEY
REALIZED IT WAS NO ON THE
GENERAL FUND. AND- DO I HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND OF THE MOST BY
SIMPLY MEMORY. THIS IS SECOND BY
. ASSEMBLY I. GREAT. IN THE
BUDGET IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY CIVIL FONG IRWIN HI-
WHEN I WHEN I WHEN I GRAY GRAY
AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON NOT VOTING
EXCUSE ME GRAYSON IS ABSENT
LIVING LEVINE I MAYES. MULLIN
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK. RIVAS.
ZERO SARAH AREN'T. DOUBLE THAT
WAS OUT AND THEN I THINK WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE. AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN- ONE. CALLED
ABSOLUTELY THOSE GRAY HI GREAT I
. MULLIN MULLIN I RIVAS
RIVERSIDE. ZERO ZERO FIVE. WELL
WE HAVE EVERYBODY ON NUMBER. TWO
NOTE. THAT'S THE MYSTERY I'M
MISUNDERSTOOD GRAYSON ON BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT HE'S COMING BACK
. OKAY WITH WELL WILL WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANOTHER FOUR
MINUTES FOR MR GRAYSON. AREAS.
MR GRAYSON. ASSEMBLY BILL. I AM
A YES THIRD WAS VOTE ON ONE AND
TWO AND THEN ON THE LAST THREE.
MISTER JEFF I KNOW BROADBAND SO-
NOW I JUST NEED TO ASK MR
GRAYSON TO SOME. I HAVE YOU HAVE
YOUR HONOR. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE. GRAYSON I. I
AM NUMBER. NINE NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE- GRAYSON I AM NUMBER TEN
AB. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. GRAYSON I
AM LET ME. YES YOU ARE. DAMIEN
IS ADJOURNED.